et
[Rires]
je crois que j'avais très envie de quand
même de d'essayer d'aller conquérir un
autre territoire en effet parce que la
médecine j'avais le sentiment d'avoir
fait un petit peu le tour cet univers de
prof les j'ai grandi dedans et toute ma
famille à part mon père qui est médecin
toute ma famille est enseignant et ça
m'a je pense donner envie de
m'intéresser à cette profession essayer
de comprendre ce qui était ce métier et
pourquoi les hommes et les femmes qui
sont derrière ces enseignants pourquoi
sont des gens quand même qui ont des
qualités assez exceptionnelles qui sont
surtout un sens de l'engagement et qui
donne voilà du sens à leur existence en
pratiquant ce métier déjà j'étais très
curieux de voir ce qu'il y avait à
proposer Thomas qui est parce que c'est
un peu la première fois qu'il fait un
film qui est pas sur le dans le milieu
médical quoi et
j'ai trouvé assez vite sa patte en fait
finalement on ça change pas grand chose
en fait que ça soit pas dans une heure
médicale parce qu'il y a toujours ce je
sais pas comment dire le format à la
fois des films très réalistes et en même
temps une forme d'humanité qui est
inhérente à tous ces films donc j'ai
retrouvé vraiment son univers c'est
dialogues il y a une manière très
particulière d'écrire aussi des scènes
de groupe etc donc j'ai trouvé que
c'était
surtout un film extrêmement intéressant
quoi moi j'ai été séduite tout de suite
par le côté chorale et collectif du film
et qui me séduisait autant humainement
de d'avoir des partenaires comme ça que
dans le côté immersion dans les salles
de prof dans leur intimité et autant la
manière dont ils font à l'école
et puis et puis l'ironie aussi du cinéma
de me dire moi ancienne mauvaise élève
j'ai la chance de jouer une professeur
de mathématiques donc il y avait
beaucoup de choses je pense que
humainement ça m'a touché et puis j'aime
le cinéma de Thomas pour ça en fait pour
le côté
l'empathie qu'il a jamais misérable de
de se mettre dans des voilà des des gens
du service public qui sont complètement
dévoués à des vocations peu reconnus et
d'imaginer leur quotidien de manière
très réaliste nous tous on a été
on a dû on a donc eu un prof en face de
nous mais l'énigme c'était la salle des
profs on passait devant et on se
demandait qu'est-ce qui pouvait se
passer derrière cette porte donc ça ça
m'a beaucoup plu et ensuite ce qu'on
ignore tous c'est le prof chez lui donc
il y a trois strates devant ses élèves
qui sa fonction
ses collègues dans la salle des profs et
puis individuellement chez lui la vie
qu'il a et j'ai trouvé que
c'était écrit justement sur sur ces
trois mouvements là à partir d'un groupe
avec de jeunes acteurs que j'admirais
déjà j'ai l'euphorie du groupe j'aime
quand il y a beaucoup de monde j'aime
quand il y a beaucoup d'avis différents
j'aime quoi il y a du bruit donc moi
aussi j'étais servi moi j'aime ça
[Rires]
mais là c'était sympa en l'occurrence
qu'on soit beaucoup
de toute façon Thomas il faut toujours
des questions sur la vocation qu'est-ce
que est-ce que je suis au bon endroit la
légitimité est-ce que telle personne est
faite pour faire ce métier c'est des
questionnements qui l'obsède je pense et
qui sont et qui sont racontés de manière
très juste dans ces films c'est une
sorte d'obsession comme ça d'essayer de
recréer la réalité mais pas au service
de du documentaire ou pas le réel pour
le réel en fait c'est c'est une vision
du réel qui est par définition déjà de
la fiction c'est ma vision à moi du réel
à laquelle vient se rajouter dans
l'interprétation des des comédiens et ça
ça m'échappe en partie ce qui m'échappe
pas c'est qu'en effet je peux les
diriger je peux les amener certaines
choses mais après ce qu'ils sont leur
personnalité ce que eux apportent au
personnage ça ça m'échappe c'est pour ça
que c'est très important pour moi de
travailler avec des acteurs en qui j'ai
extrêmement confiance que je connais
très bien lui ce qu'il veut c'est que le
personnage soit vivant pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont bien plus de présence et
beaucoup plus d'acuité demandée le
spectateurs et coup de voir un type une
fille vivante un groupe vivant je pense
à la scène du réfectoire je pensais
comme ça vraiment j'ai le sentiment que
c'était ça qui voulait alors c'est notre
bonheur à nous arriver qu'en mettant en
scène nous demande d'être vivant et qui
lui parviennent et que en tracteur nous
y parvenions on sent moi j'ai fait une
scène là la scène du Conseil des
discipline c'est on l'a fait en temps
réel c'est chaque prise durait une heure
ça donne un côté un peu théâtrale quoi
enfin théâtrale et du coup extrêmement
naturel parce qu'on filmait on a filmé
toute cette scène et c'était pour
partout pareil parce que il adore faire
des impro donc en fait il y a une scène
écrite et on improvise le début et la
fin donc ça met en situation et après
moi ce que j'aime bien là-dedans c'est
qu'on passe notre temps à jouer quoi
tandis qu'il y a beaucoup de films où on
attend beaucoup quoi je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de parler à la place des profs
et de leur dire comment il devrait faire
leur métier donc moi je suis pas capable
de dire voilà ce serait mieux si vous
faisiez comme ça par contre le petit
début de solution que je donne et que la
particularité de mon collège
c'est que tous ces profs tous ces
personnages ils font ils font corps il y
a cette solidarité cette confraternité
et je pense c'est solidarité qui est
beaucoup lié au choix des comédiens que
que à ceux que j'ai choisi mais qui ont
eu beaucoup d'affection sur le tournage
entre eux c'est un peu l'objectif que je
m'étais fixé je pense que c'est un peu
la solution face à la solitude et la
difficulté de ce métier ça peut pas être
une solution suffisante mais c'est
indispensable pour pour qu'on puisse
supporter la difficulté de la pratique
de l'enseignement